hoy he venido a contarnos una historia
la historia de cómo elige a un grupo de
amigos para limpiar una playa pero antes
quiero hablaros un poquito de mí llegué
aquí en la ciudad de valència y todos
los veranos desde muy pequeñito he
veraneado en el camping de la playa de
la devesa del saler
y recuerdo de aquella época el ir en
pelota picada jugar con las olas hacer
la croqueta en las dunas del saler
recuerdo en recuerdo esos momentos como
algo muy bonito y muy especial de mi
infancia
también después vino la juventud
adolescencia y después entré en la
universidad y me fui a la ciudad de
cádiz a estudiar ciencias del mar
oceanografía
me empapé de todo lo que había que saber
sobre el medio marino y me empapé
también de muchas otras cosas y
experiencias que definen hoy la persona
que soy o por lo menos en mi opinión
pero la historia empieza cuando vuelvo a
valencia a ese escenario de mi infancia
en la playa de la devesa del saler
encontré un panorama muy distinto al que
recordaba tenía unos colores diferentes
no quiero decir especiales pero
diferentes esos colores que no pegaban
mucho con la naturaleza me refiero al
amarillo de la garrafa de lejía al azul
de las botellas de plástico y también
nos encontramos este monstruo que
después de mucho mucho esfuerzo de tirar
de él no conseguimos moverlo ni dos
centímetros pese a que la intención era
muy buena no conseguimos mover este este
gran residuo también encontramos muchas
muchas basuras muchos plásticos de
diferentes formas y colores
y junto a un grupo de amigos para
realizar la limpieza de playa los engañe
diciendo que después iba a haber
cervezas que iba a haber voleibol que
íbamos a disfrutar de una mañana de
playa muy agradable y empezamos a hacer
la limpieza con la intención de aguantar
una hora llegamos a estar hasta 3 horas
limpiando la playa porque algo nos
entraba dentro de decir esto me lo tengo
que llevar también es que esto no lo
puedo dejar es que es que estuvimos todo
este tiempo llenando 30 bolsas de basura
de tamaño doméstico en un tramo a lo
mejor de un kilómetro de longitud
cargamos estas bolsas de basura desde la
espalda y lo llevamos a la papelera más
cercana que estaba en la puesta del
socorrista y en ese momento teníamos una
satisfacción no una sensación de héroes
y heroínas que estábamos haciendo este
gran esfuerzo
y nos encantó porque vimos que de verdad
habíamos significado un impacto positivo
en la playa y la habíamos devuelto un
poquito a la imagen que recordábamos de
ella de cuando éramos más pequeños
ese día algo cambió dentro de nosotros
empezamos a sentir algo contradictorio
una sensación agridulce
habíamos limpiado una playa pero
sabíamos que esa no iba a ser la
solución entonces empezamos a hacernos
preguntas de dónde viene esta basura
porque hay tanta basura en esta playa
cómo podemos hacer para evitarlo
entonces dijimos vale estas preguntas
nuevas no nos las hacíamos antes hemos
empezado hacernos estas preguntas a raíz
de tocar con nuestras propias manos la
problemática los residuos y decidimos
que íbamos a hacer más actividades como
esta todos los meses para que cada vez
más personas participasen y se hiciesen
conscientes y se hiciesen las mismas
preguntas que nosotros nos habíamos
hecho entonces así conseguiríamos estar
un poquito más cerca de la solución
definitiva
hoy en día reunimos cerca de 200
personas todos los días que limpiamos
una playa hemos participado en proyectos
internacionales hemos quitado muchísimos
muchísimos kilos de plástico y de
basuras de nuestras playas para que os
hagáis una idea retiramos del orden de
1500 bastoncillos de oídos 2600 piezas
de plástico y 3700 colillas cada hora
que limpiamos la playa
también participamos en limpieza
subacuáticas desde la superficie con los
kayaks o en la playa más cercana
también hacemos talleres de educación
ambiental hemos decidido llevar los
coles a la playa para que desde las más
tempranas empiecen a concienciarse y
hacerse esas preguntas y también hemos
llevado las playas a las aulas
comentando todos los datos que recogemos
de las basuras de las playas para que
ellos mismos sean también conscientes y
se hagan una idea de la magnitud del
problema porque una cosa despertó en la
playa y otra cosa es ver los números
hemos llegado cerca de 3500 niños y
niñas en los últimos años
lo que está claro es que el plástico es
un problema inunda nuestras playas
nuestros mares nuestros océanos ríos
montañas e incluso nuestras calles
es un problema que tenemos y que además
sabemos que el plástico no es un
material biodegradable que se degrada y
desaparece en nuestro entorno sino que
es un material foto de agradable que se
degrada con la radiación del sol y la
erosión del mar convirtiéndose cada vez
en partículas más pequeñas el problema
de este material es que al convertirse
en trocitos microscópicos que llegan a
medir 10 micras de ancho para que os
hagáis una idea es el ancho de un
cabello humano vale entonces ese tamaño
microscópico se convierte en un problema
irreversible ya no es muy complicado
retirarlo del medio porque con ésta con
esta longitud se convierte en parte de
la composición química del agua en parte
de la composición del suelo y también
entre la cadena trófica de los animales
marinos que utilizan el agua para
respirar filtrando el oxígeno
nosotros con este con este problema
hemos pensado en las posibilidades que
tiene ese residuo antes de llegar a este
tamaño está microscópico y reversible y
antes de esas oportuna antes de ese
problema tenemos la oportunidad de
aplicarle las tres erres que como bien
sabéis es la de reducir reutilizar y por
último reciclar hemos desarrollado un
proyecto que se basa en los principios
de reutilización y reciclaje
lo hemos bautizado con el nombre plastic
friendly aquí tenemos un pequeño tráiler
del proyecto para que lo podáis ver y
mientras os explico se trata
de una planta de reciclaje portátil de
tamaño pequeñito en el que consta de
tres máquinas casi cuatro es una
trituradora de plásticos una inyectora
que es como una jeringuilla muy grande
que calienta las minutas de plástico y
las inyecta en los moldes que tenemos
también tenemos una prensa hidráulica
para fijar los moldes y además un
pequeño horno que hemos rescatado de los
contenedores para poder hacerlos
fundidos y hacer tablillas como ésta
estas son las tablillas hechas 100% de
tapones reciclados y además son las
tablillas que nosotros en las playas
utilizamos para cuantificar las basuras
que recogemos entonces hemos empezado
empezando por estos objetos porque nos
resultan muy útiles y así no las
compramos del material plástico virgen
como podéis ver hemos hecho diferentes
objetos y además de estos objetos que
has visto en el vídeo también hemos
diseñado relojes de pared hemos hecho
llaveros con el logo de nuestra
asociación hemos hecho peines de tablas
de surf para trabajar con escuelas de
surf que son los que más cerca están del
de la playa y también hemos hecho
peonzas como la que tengo hoy aquí vale
entonces la finalidad de este proyecto
es transformar el estigma del residuo y
convertirla en recursos para así poder
quitar kilos y kilos de nuestros
vertederos de nuestras playas
está claro que estamos saturados de
plástico
qué podemos hacer para evitarlo desde
1907 que se inventó el plástico
hemos sufrido avances impresionantes en
tecnología hemos avanzado en
comunicación con los dispositivos
móviles y hemos generado niveles de
confort que sin este material no serían
posible pero nuestro problema ha sido
olvidarnos de cómo gestionamos esos
objetos una vez terminan su vida útil ya
si ya no funciona ya no nos sirven lo
descartamos entonces ha sido mucho
tiempo el que hemos utilizado y hemos
olvidado
estos objetos una vez terminada su vida
útil y ahora estamos sufriendo las
consecuencias
este gran problema ha despertado muchas
mentes inquietas para buscar soluciones
a medio largo plazo pero en esta lucha
los pequeños gestos como éste son los
que más fuerza tienen nosotros y
nosotras cada día convirtiéndonos en
activistas preocupándonos un poquito en
el impacto que generamos en nuestro
entorno
cambiando un poquito nuestros hábitos de
consumo
hoy no quiero daros el sermón de lo mal
que estamos del problema que tenemos en
nuestros mares ni mucho menos
no quiero desmotivaron al contrario hoy
he venido aquí para deciros que el
cambio es posible de hecho el cambio es
lo único que nos puede asegurar un
futuro sostenible hablando de cambios
os quiero contar un poquito los cambios
que yo he hecho en mi vida personal
empecé con un pequeño cambio que a lo
mejor para muchos es muy sencillo de
hacer pero yo tenía un pequeño freno
mental desde mucho desde hace mucho
tiempo a los 12 años deje de utilizar la
bici por una gran caída que tuve tuve
hay un pequeño accidente trauma y deje
de usar la bici nos volvía a empezar a
usarla una vez volví a valència me quite
los miedos del tráfico de la gente de
los coches y me di cuenta que valencia
es una ciudad muy amable para utilizar
la bici para ir con la bici a todos
lados y además descubrí que pese a que
me han robado 7 bicis en los últimos 3
años se me han pinchado me han puesto
chinchetas en las cubiertas de la bici
para arruinarme el día imagino aún así
sigo pensando fervientemente que es la
mejor alternativa de movilidad en
nuestra ciudad
también deciros el cambio también normal
podríamos decir ahora hace unos años no
era tanto de ir a la compra con las
bolsas de tela reutilizables mucho mejor
que no las bolsas de supermercado que
sólo tienen cinco minutos de vida útil
luego los descartamos y tardan años y
años en degradarse
pero hace unos pocos meses de un paso
más compramos las bolsitas de rejilla
no sé si sois familiarizados con ella
para la fruta y la verdura vale
descubrimos mi pareja y yo cuando íbamos
a comprar al supermercado a la frutería
que era una herramienta muy curiosa para
despertar y crear conversación sea con
el tendero sean con las personas que
estaban en la cola y siempre nos
preguntaban qué tal van esas bolsitas
donde las habéis comprado de verdad
funcionan
y nosotros siempre conversamos con ellos
y les decimos que la chica que nos lo
vendió nos dijo que estas bolsas nos
iban a enterrar o sea que tienen que
durar para siempre y eso va muy perfecto
en la línea de las bolsas de plástico de
la frutería tienen un solo uso y además
tardan lo que tarda en llegar a casa y
luego se van a la basura las podemos
reutilizar si tenemos gato no sé si lo
habéis probado pero para limpiar las
cacas de los gatos va fantástico
pero después también los cajeros las
cajeras de los supermercados nos motivan
muchísimo porque nos dicen que cada día
hay más gente que las está utilizando y
eso nos dibuja una sonrisa en la cara
espectacular
después de caras para fuera la gente
como yo que nos gusta un poco la
naturaleza hacer picnics con los amigos
al aire libre o incluso a la gente que
tiene que llevar la comida al trabajo
porque no tiene tiempo y tiene que comer
allí en el trabajo tenemos otra
alternativa y es este pequeño estuche de
tela que me regalaron una vez y aquí
llevo siempre los utensilios de madera
la pajita que como sabéis es un gran
problema con el tema de las bebidas para
llevar la cuchara que tiene el tenedor
por el otro lado vale y simplemente con
este gesto añadimos un poquito de
servilleta de tela y si se te ha
olvidado pues podemos usar el estuche
simplemente con este gesto nos damos
cuenta que esta comida ese picnic se
convierte en residuo cero o casi residuo
cero y es se sienta muchísimo mejor la
comida al ver que es tan fácil recoger y
disfrutar de la comida sin preocuparte
de generar más residuos y esto de
puertas para afuera pero de puertas para
adentro también hay un mundo que no
solemos pensar cuando hablamos de
residuos y es la cocina el baño si
empezamos a hacer algún cambio de estos
nos damos cuenta enseguida de que
utensilios podemos sustituir o reducir
en la cocina como el estropajo los
productos de limpieza que tenemos
siempre debajo del fregadero verdad que
tenemos 100 y sólo usamos 3
y además en el cuarto de baño la
cosmética hoy en día existen muchísimas
opciones sin envase y además súper
importante no testado en animales
y además vemos que nuestra bañera está
llena de mascarillas capilares
acondicionadores champús geles cremas un
montón de botes que al final usamos tres
de todos los 79 10 que tenemos en la
bañera entonces os invito a hacer este
ejercicio para reducir ese impacto de
envases [ __ ] los tres productos que
usáis siempre y descartar el resto o
usarlo hasta que se acaben pero luego no
volváis a rellenarlo entonces no os
daréis cuenta de que no pasa nada
seguimos oliendo bien seguimos
lavándonos todos los días no hay ningún
problema no cambia nada no es nada del
otro mundo y aún así estaréis reduciendo
muchísimo el impacto de envases de
plástico en vuestra casa
pero lo importante aquí es ser
responsables con la decisión que tomamos
nosotros somos los responsables de cada
gesto que hacemos en nuestro día a día y
por tanto de sus consecuencias yo no soy
un cero western yo no tengo una vida
cero weiss ni soy el más sostenible pero
lo importante es que cada día me
esfuerzo un poquito más en serlo
tengo mis caprichos que no sé si algún
día podré quitarme como por ejemplo
viajar una vez al año lo más lejos
posible para alejarme de desconectar y
cargar esa barrita de energía para
volver a rutina con más fuerza
pero
lo que os quiero contar hoy es que la
vida de activista es algo que podemos
hacer ahora por propia voluntad pero si
esperamos un poquito más serán las
circunstancias las que nos obliguen a
cambiar
yo no os digo que vengáis a limpiar la
playa todos los meses aunque se
engancharía porque una vez limpias una
playa ya no volvéis a mirar con los
mismos ojos a la playa
y es muy adictivo y tenemos testigos de
gente que ha venido y ha repetido y ha
traído a sus amigos y nos hemos juntado
allí una gran familia
pero sí que es el momento de ser
responsables y conscientes de todas las
decisiones que hacemos y del impacto que
generamos en nuestro medio ambiente
imaginaros por un momento que toda la
audiencia que estáis aquí hacéis un
cambio de los que he mencionado en
vuestro día a día ahora imaginaros que
todas las 7.300 millones de personas que
somos en el planeta se convirtiesen en
activistas por un día yo solo puedo
pensar en los limpias que estarían las
playas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]